[Music]
[Music]
my name is Roberto Gabbar OSHA I'm the
owner and the pizza maker for Antonia
here in York City the pizza fleet has
come from nipples nipples are very
famous for fried food Friday Pizza is a
different way they cook with inside the
oil Antonio Cervino 20 years ago decided
do something frame and put special
tomato sauce or goo and smoked
mozzarella in top of this fried dough
the Montanaro a finished inside the oven
of course I think you fry it tastes
better for the Montanaro
you need near further flour we use a
type 1 flower from Caputo because this
flower have a lot more natural v doing a
natural meter out and plus a more
detestable so the flower it's very
important we start to stretch the dough
and make a hole in the top so all the
air
the gas is inside a no will be separated
at that point we put inside the fryer we
use a canola oil the most important
thing you fry a good oil when you start
to become a color we take off at the
point we put this or I could we make it
here now so this as a sacred salt we use
the Italian Peter to mission from the
San Marzano area no because American
tomato is not good but because they're
the flavor they soil we have an either
make you a totally different profile in
a unique test for the salt in after that
we put today smoked water buffalo
mozzarella from northeast new poses area
for cobbler with a mozzarella was
and we put some basil in a
parmigiano-reggiano at the point that
pizza go in the mouth of the oven the
oven is from nipples the stone inside is
volcanic stone is called [ __ ] police
Avengers from Sorrento it's very small
dome and a small mouth they keep it
simple to very high the oil evaporated
and melted the cheese and warming up of
the sauce we put the cutting board a
captain for pizza and Israeli deliver on
the table what we've launched the
Montana the first time it was incredible
usually the first things that you sell
delicious a morsel is the margarita the
mountain I was beat every day the
margarita the people can adjust I won't
try the Montana every part of the trial
a fried pizza they're all his last soil
ey imagine me I stopped Nikita when I
was 38 years old before I was a farmer
cheese maker and when I was 28 I want to
change and I went to school in Naples
for pizza I think because I'm Italian
and my mom was a farmer I think it's I
my blood was it pizza maker pizzas
become my life I love to do it is so
much history inside and I feel every
time I bring the pizza to my customer
I'll bring one piece a story
you
[Music]